und über die politische menge lage an
diesem tag kann ich nun sprechen mit
georg kurz ist der bundessprecher der
grünen jugend guten tag in die
hauptstadt
guten morgen das werde ich in hallo herr
kurz die kriegen ja ihre
wunschkonstellation nach der
bundestagswahl das ist offenbar die
ampel jedenfalls gibt es ja heute mal
ein erstes gespräch mit welcher er mit
welchen erwartungen schauen sie an
dieses gespräch
ja ich glaube mit ähnlichen erwartungen
wie millionen andere menschen nämlich
das ist ja nicht reicht einfach zu sagen
wir machen jetzt mit neuen regierung
weiter mit neuen parteien einfach ein
bisschen am status quo und doktoren und
ein bisschen klimaschutz sondern dass
wir jetzt einen wirklichen aufbruch
brauchen das zb klimaschutz die
einhaltung des pariser
klimaschutzabkommens nichts mehr ist was
man einfach irgendwie zu den akten legt
sondern was man in konkrete
sofortmaßnahmen merkt dass soziale
gerechtigkeit nichts mehr ist was man
irgendwie auf wahlplakate papst sondern
was menschen in ihrem geldbeutel spüren
in ihrer lebensrealität dass
menschenrechte nichts mehr sinn für die
gesetzbücher sondern dass die wirklich
die basis von regierungshandeln werden
beispielsweise an den außengrenzen es
gibt so wahnsinnig viel zu tun und schön
dass es jetzt das offensichtlich
konstruktive gespräche gibt aber da muss
jetzt auch wirklich sehr sehr viel
passieren da gibt es jetzt einen sehr
hohen erwartungsdruck ja und wenn es
denn dazu kommt dann wird das ganze
geführt im kanzleramt von der spd
namentlich von olaf scholz jetzt haben
sie auch gerade das wort aufbruch wieder
benutzt annalena baerbock benutzt ist
auch sehr häufig eher kurz was lässt sie
den glauben dass mit dieser spd die ja
die letzten zwölf jahre auch mit dabei
war in berlin am kabinettstisch dass mit
diesen sozialdemokraten tatsächlich ein
aufbruch möglich ist
vielleicht leicht wird es nicht ich
glaube dass die erwartet das ist jetzt
einfach so durch flutscht und dann gibt
es ab morgen super gerechte super tolle
politik für alle die hat glaube ich
niemand aber ich glaube es gibt schon
ein gemeinsames bekenntnis und
gemeinsames interesse daran so einen
echten aufbruch zu schaffen aber ja also
dafür muss es jetzt ja offensichtlich
noch viele verhandlungen geben wenn das
alles so einfach wäre dann braucht es
die ganzen sondierungs und
koalitionsgespräche einfach kann jeder
dazu braucht man keine spitzenpolitiker
vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen
intensiver einsteigen in das für sie ja
sehr wichtige thema klimaschutz was
wären aus ihrer sicht aus sicht der
grünen jugend so ein paar es herrsche so
ein paar pflöcke die da ihre leute
durchsetzen müssten
ich glaube und das müssen ja nicht nur
wir durchsetzen sondern das ja der
planet der extreme anforderungen an uns
stellt eine gute zukunft für uns dafür
muss 1,5 grad politik also die
einhaltung von klimazielen die überhaupt
ein gutes leben ermöglichen dafür muss
das die basis allen regierungshandeln
sein sonst wird diese regierung
scheitern zwangsläufig und das muss ich
eben runterbrechen nicht indem man sagt
gut haben wir beschlossen als nettes
fernziel 420 irgendwann legen wir zu den
akten sollen in sofortmaßnahmen im
konkreten regierungshandeln in jeden
einzelnen sektor das heißt wir müssen
wahnsinnig schnell aus der kohle
aussteigen wir müssen wahnsinnig schnell
öffentliche verkehrsinfrastruktur
aufbauen um wenige autos angewiesen zu
sein wir uns wahnsinnig schnell die
landwirtschaft reformieren um aufzuhören
damit wahnsinnig viele emissionen in die
luft zu pusten die böden kaputt zu
machen und so weiter das heißt es gibt
so viele bereiche in denen parallel
jetzt mit volldampf mannes in einer
legislatur aufgeholt werden muss was in
den letzten 30 jahren verschlafen wurde
über die konkreten einzelmaßnahmen waren
genau welche kraftwerke abgeschaltet
wird und so weiter da gibt es sicherlich
viel verhandlungsspielraum herkommenden
all der ersten musiker sein herr kurz
ihre vorschläge werden auch vor allem
waren sie nicht viel geld kosten wo soll
denn das geld angesichts der
verschuldung der staatlichen kassen wo
soll denn das geld herkommen
ja das ist geld kostet ist ja nur die
eine hälfte der wahrheit vor allem ist
dieses jahr investitionen die sich
lohnen die für uns eine gute zukunft
schaffen und das ist ja der kern von
investitionen dass die sich rentieren
dass das geld nicht einfach weg ist und
verpulvert sondern dass es sich eben
lohnt langfristig und das sehen wir ja
klar schon auf der welt die welt
verändert sich alle nationen müssen
klimaneutral werden und es gibt keine
alternative dazu diesen wandel anzugehen
es gibt nur die chance in der cer
beherzt sie auch selbst bestimmt sehr
schnell anzugehen
um davon profitieren zu können und darum
geht es jetzt und ja dafür werden wir
sehr viel investieren müssen und
gleichzeitig aber für uns alle ein
besseres leben dafür bekommen und ich
würde sagen das lohnt sich nun waren im
vorfeld dieser sondierungen oder diese
koalitionsgespräche wir wissen ja noch
nicht wie es ausgeht die präsidentin der
rechnungshof hilfe gerade gestern davor
die staatsverschuldung noch weiter
aufzublähen und eventuell neue kreative
in anführungsstrichen wege zu finden da
über andere möglichkeiten die
staatsverschuldung weiter zu steigern
das sagen die ja auch mit blick auf die
generationengerechtigkeit also mit blick
auf ihre generation es ist ein
gesichtspunkt der für sie zugänglich ist
oder sagen sie nein nein jetzt muss
wirklich ganz ganz viel auch vielleicht
über die schuldenbremse hinaus
investiert werden ja also mit der
legende dass das irgendwie meiner
generation nutzen würde öffentliche
infrastruktur verfallen zu lassen muss
wirklich dringend schluss gemacht werde
ich überhaupt keine lust mehr dafür
benutzt zu werden das gegenteil ist
richtig wir haben jetzt so viele jahre
nicht investiert und damit brutale
schulden aufgebaut schimmelige schulen
das ja nicht nur der klimaschutz sind
schulden weg rationalisiert die
krankenhäuser wo gesundheitsversorgung
in weiten teilen am lernen schwierig
wird es sind schulden eben fehlender
klimaschutz das immer noch bestehende
bahninfrastruktur verfallen lassen statt
jetzt milliarden in die hand zu nehmen
für einen guten öffentlichen verkehr für
alle das sind schulden und das sind
alles fehlen der klimaschutz sind die
größten schulden die man meiner
generation überlassen kann und da also
dass da immer noch so getan wird als
würde mir dass irgendwas nutzen wenn man
die dinge die ich für ein gutes leben
braucht einfach verfallen lässt aber
hauptsache eine schwarze null am ende so
können wir nicht in die zukunft gehen
und ich hoffe
dass es wirklich alle parteien die
hörtest und ihren verstanden haben sagt
georg kurz der sprecher der grünen
jugend vielen dank dafür
danke für ihre zeit und einen schönen
tag noch nach berlin sehr gern ebenso
liebe grüße